[Music]
English lessons hello today's mini
English lesson is about connected speech
before you remember Anna's lesson I am
here to talk to you about two more plots
catenation no not a bunch of cats in the
van cm calcination is when you have two
words and the first word ends in a
consonant and the next one starts with a
vowel ah ice cream this turns to nice
cream nice an ice cream next one is an
apple not Knuffle an apple number two is
intrusion
did you see the football match yesterday
wasn't it good Oh brilliant wonderful
fans i intrusion is when you have
something that comes in between two
words an intrusive sound just do it this
is the intrusive sound what now what
have you heard this before
Nike so every time you see Mike you will
think of intrusion and British Council
number two we have I am a teacher this
is the intrusive sound yeah I am I am a
teacher I am a students why is connected
speech important because it will make
you sound more like a native speaker to
sound more like a native speaker
remember fascination and intrusion I am
a teacher I am a students I would like
an ice cream just do it
[Music]